we are under the lights this evening as
we get you set for another edition of
baseball on the show
coming up we've got a good matchup in
store between the miami marlins
and the oakland a's interlink baseball
comes your way next
into the box corey dickerson and we are
set for baseball here this evening
and now pitch on the way
first pitch cutter that's by him for
strike one
and he fouls this one off the offensive
game plan today is certainly to see the
ball up
this guy is known on the mound for
sinker change-up combination
he's going to try and establish down in
the zone to get swinging a miss or
ground balls consistently
you have to find something above the
belt to get loose on
and this is taken for a call third
strike as the leadoff man is set down to
open up the ball game
the center field next it'll be starling
martay
[Applause]
changed up on him and dropped it in for
a cold strike
game time temperature tonight 62 degrees
but should drop into the 50s before
we're done
a little quick on that swing and he
finds himself behind owen two
lays off that time and it's one and two
fly ball out to straight away right
biscotti's there for it and that's the
second out of the inning
so now here is jesus aguilar the first
chance for him here in the top of the
first with nobody on
now here it comes
hard hit ball to second
rowanda olson will take care of him at
first and that ends the inning
now into the box ramon laureano he'll
lead things off here in the bottom half
of the first
the center fielder number 22. pitch on
the way
liner towards second and that finds some
outfield grass hits a base hit
and a nice job to get the ball in
quickly he'll be held to a single here
with nobody out
[Applause]
to him it's ball one can't get around
quick enough and that'll move the count
to one and one
lucky he got a piece right there he was
definitely late on that pitch
after seeing a previous off speed pitch
pitch out
nothing doing lauriano gets his lead at
first nobody out
[Music]
[Applause]
sinker misses there and now he's in
trouble three and one
there's the heavy sinker right there
what makes that pitch so
difficult to hit is not only does it
change eye levels it actually changes
plane
you go to hit it at one position and
it's six to eight inches dropping off
the table
and chasing your hands bad explodes as
this has popped up
and he'll steer clear of the flying
debris to make the catch here for the
first down
so now to the plate matt chapman batting
third
the third baseman matt becomes set
here's the nothing in nothing pitch oh
he couldn't catch up with the gas that
time
now a ball grounded to short this could
be two to second for one
relay to first in time and just like
that this side is retired
new ending set to get underway and set
to go as the third baseman
brian anderson
first offering
hit weekly back to the mound
pro is in time for the first out of the
second
one out bases empty and up next former
san francisco minor
league property adam duvall
[Applause]
swing and a miss on the sinker 0-1 you
have to find a way to lay off that low
sinker there is just
no way to do any damage you're just
looking at a swing and a drive sent out
toward the gap
a leap but he won't get it it's off the
wall
duval takes the turn at third he wants
it all and he's
safe at the plate as they take the lead
[Applause]
standing in now miguel rojas as he takes
a cold strike at the knees it's owen one
lifted in the air toward the line and
right but scotty's on the move
in there the base hit running hard he's
digging for second
around second now and headed for third
and he will make it all the way to third
now as that mistake proves a costly one
indeed
and that'll bring in garrett cooper as
he will take a fast ball in there at the
knees for strike one
drive and that's a base hit into center
field and that'll score the run from
third as they go up two to nothing now
[Applause]
into the box as the change up to him
drops in there for the first strike
first shot for him here with a runner at
first now and one away
that's taken now it's owen two
and it's fouled away
[Music]
looked like the cut fastball there and
he got him to swing through it for the
second out
two down with the runner at first and up
next will be the big catcher jorge
alfaro
one ball no strikes to count
he's ready here's the 1-0 easy fly ball
into shallow center field
long run buddy gets there to track this
one down
and a very nicely recorded out number
three
now to the plate tony kemp he'll be the
one to start things out for oakland in
their half of the sixth inning
to the left side reigned in
throw to first is in time for the first
down
so one gone for the a's in their half of
the six
digging in now ramon lauriano
first pitch of the a b on its way
hey the guy on the mound is absolutely
pounding the zone and that's why he's
been able to stay and pitch deep into
this game
lofted in the air out toward right
center
duvall is over to his right as he puts
this one away
two down so the next
bat will be mark canna he comes in over
two thus far
into center field line drive base hit
up next the third baseman
so that brings up the always intense
matt chapman
he swings and sends a bullet to right
field and that's in there base hit
now
and that'll bring up matt olson as he'll
try to hold back on the swing but he
went around for the first strike
no hits to this point
there's a swing and a missile sent out
to center field
and goodbye this one ain't coming back
in at the plate is sean murphy
yes he'll pick on the first pitch and
line one back up the middle and that's a
base head
he takes the turn and heads for second
and now he'll get into scoring position
with two away
the designated hitter at the plate mitch
moreland
and he fouls this one off he's over two
in the ball game so far
comes set vo1
three runs already home here
[Applause]
hot shot down the line uh reach as he
makes the catch and he took a header
along with it but he saved
extra bases as the side is retired
and now in the box miguel rojas if you
remember he motored around the diamond
for an
inside the park home run last at-bat
good way to start it on the outside
corner for strike one
missed low and inside with it one and
one
and now a pitch on the way
that's in there on the outer half one
and two now
hey i still believe in my heart the best
pitch there's a well-executed fastball
down and away and that's exactly what
that is
he swings at that that's off the end of
the bat that's not hard contact at all
and that's an easy out for the defense
so now into the boxes garrett cooper
one for two he's singled and grounded
out so far
laid off but a cold strike as that
caught the outside
boy that's just about in the catcher's
glove there it's owen too
what a well-executed sinker right there
there's really nothing you can do with
that pitch you're either burying it into
the ground
or fouling it off your shin bases are
empty one man out
[Applause]
hard hit ball to second and that finds
its way through for a base hit
[Applause]
the battery sandias and on the first
pitch he grounds foul
he's hitless in his two at-bats so far
set to deliver the 0-1 swinging a looper
to left
here comes the left fielder but he won't
get there
it falls in
[Music]
no hits in two trips to the plate for
him in the ball game
late that time for a strike
the 1-1 is swung on and missed for
strike number two
did well just to make contact there as
he spoils off a good change up
looking for the strikeout here's the 1-2
cooper on second dias is over at first
with one away
and here's a swing and a miss and that
folks is a big
out number two so the lineup flips over
and
digging in corey dickerson two outs and
two runners aboard here in the seventh
inning
cut fastball in there for a called
strike
rolled slowly down the first baseline
throw on the first will be in time and
the marlins can cash in here
outfielder stephen piscotty the next to
hit he's hoping to avoid the hat trick
he struck out in
each of his first two played appearances
so far
popped up cooper over to his left makes
the play one away
here's elvis anderson third trip to the
plate for him here tonight
oh for two at this point swung on and
missed for the first strike
great job by the pitcher right there
changing eye levels we all know he's a
sinker ball pitcher
but if he could throw some four seamers
up in the zone like that
it could work for him and that will be a
base hit for andrus
james poynt enters to make an appearance
on the mound as he inherits a runner at
first with one out in the inning
so now to the plate tony count as he'll
try and hold off the swing but this
one's in there for strike one
oh for two from him so far in this one
[Music]
sent on the ground out to second and a
good effort on the dive that time but
this will get by him for a base hit
and with that the go ahead runs up to
second now with only one away
number 22 and that'll bring in ramon
laureano
as he swings and hits a laser to right
and that's in there base hit
the relay and it's in time he's out at
second as a good relay gets him
[Applause]
tried to check it and it's all in one
he's got a hit in three at bats to this
point
all right back to him on the mound and
he'll flip it onto first and with it
that ends the inning
now to the plate here is starling martin
he'll lead things off here in this
one-run contest
on the ground or the right side field it
cleanly
throw on to first in time so the leadoff
man is set down to open up ending number
eight
so to the plate the marlins d-h jesus
aguilar
he doubled his last time through yeah he
jumped all over that first pitch last
time up
interested to see if he has the same
approach this ab
this is why the manager pencils these
guys in the middle of the order
big spot time for them to get back in
this game with a couple quality abs
piscotti is there two down
so two gone now in the miami eighth and
that will bring up the outfielder brian
anderson
third baseman hugging the line here now
the first pitch
and a ball one and up
[Music]
faces are empty here with two men out
and a strike to even the count one and
one
he took something off of it there it's
one and two
[Applause]
into the wind-up and the pitch
ronda olson will take care of him at
first and that ends the inning
bottom of any number eight set to go and
that'll give way to the third baseman
matt chapman
first pitch of the av on its way that's
a good take on a fastball out of the
zone
hey i get it he's looking for a ball to
drive but that ball was a little bit too
far up in his own
that's one you normally pop right up and
a fastball here that's taken for ball
two
ball out to straight away right field
right fielder is on the run
he's there and records the first down
[Music]
next will be the cleanup hitter matt
olsen well man this is one of the
problems this guy's a
good fastball particularly low fast ball
hitter
it doesn't matter how hard or how low
you throw it that's right into this
wheelhouse
what you want to do with this guy is
move the ball from the belt up to get
him to chase something that
that maybe he'll pop up in the infield
ready to deal here's the 1-1 fouled off
again and now he's in a
and two hole
here's the pitch that misses and we're
even at two and two
we just saw a fastball right there i
would not be shocked if he tries to get
this guy to go fishing right here and
drops a little off-speed pitch in the
dirt
2-2 [ __ ] has found a way
pitch on the way
4-3 our score here as we play the eighth
popped him up
and he'll put this away for the second
out
stepping in once again is sean murphy
he's working on a one for three thus far
first pitch on the way oh he just blows
the fastball by him for strike one
hey if you're able to blow a first pitch
fastball by a guy gotta believe that
pitch is coming again right here
fly ball out to straight away right
duval
gets there for the catch and then
number 14 adam duvall
and now time is called and the reliever
is warm out there
[Music]
[Applause]
he's set and the pitch
[Applause]
a ball and a strike swing and a miss on
a nasty slider right there always felt
toughest pitch in the game
if you're a guy who'd like to work the
big part of the field you were on that
fastball middle away
that slider looked like a heater for
about 56 feet
six inches the count now with two and
two
fastball
[Applause]
next up miguel rojas he's two for three
and looking for more here
and this pitch is taken on the inner
half for strike one
and this guy's got some of the nastiest
stuff in the game and it is absolutely
no fun for an offense to try and piece
together
any type of attack when he's throwing
this stuff the battery
the first ready now is garrett cooper
wheels and deals here's the first pitch
one run game here in the top of the
ninth
and this is swung on and missed so now
they find themselves down to their final
strike tonight
miami down to their last strike and he
gets strike
three called to end it here and with
that this one is over
hey this was a pretty tightly played
game got a little bit of everything in
this one some timely hitting
runs on the board keep pitching and
defense in certain spots
this one was a fun one to watch and it's
a 4-3
finish in this evening's ball game the
oakland aids
jumped ahead in the 7th inning and never
gave the lead back
chris bassett earns the victory on the
mound so that'll do it for us for mark
derosa dan plezak heidi watney and
our entire crew i'm matt vasquez you've
been watching
mlb the show for more make your way over
to the new website theshow.com
[Music]
first for the victorious athletics four
runs on nine hits
no errors they left five men on base